m
ce lundi 2 mai le pôle emploi de saint
pierre et le pôle insertion du conseil
départemental ont organisé un après-midi
d'ateliers thématiques à destination des
seniors
une manifestation organisée en
partenariat avec la caf la mission
sociale rsa la cité des métiers et
l'association la fusée l'occasion de
réunir plusieurs acteurs afin de
proposer de multiples informations et
réponse au public de plus de 55 ans
bénéficiant du rsa depuis plus de deux
ans l'origine de cette manifestation pro
vient donc de l'animation des équipes
pluridisciplinaires que je préside au
nom du conseil départemental dans cette
commission dont on traite de dossiers
dans le cadre du dispositif et rsa et
autour de cette commission siège
notamment des partenaires la caf le pôle
emploi le département et des
bénéficiaires du rsa donc dans les
échanges qui avoue sein de cette
commission une idée de projet à immerger
portant sur un public très précis les
personnes âgées
enfin les seniors on dira plutôt le
public senior de 55 à 60 alors cette
opération est né dana quatre constats
concernant des seniors cette opération
que nous avons intitulé seniors où en
êtes-vous donc pendant une après midi 70
bénéficiaires du rsa depuis au moins
deux ans et âgés de plus de 50 ans vont
pouvoir avoir des réponses autour de
l'emploi du numérique de la retraite du
revenu de solidarité qu'on appelle le
rso et de la prime d'activité pour le
conseil départemental il est important
de redynamiser les seniors dans leur
démarche de recherche d'emploi et de
faciliter l'accès à leurs droits bien
écoutez je suis persuadé que c'est une
première
déjà dans le sud est que cette
cette journée où cette demi-journée est
bénéfique parce que en fait les seniors
comme vous voyez sont demandeurs
puisqu'ils sont là ils sont allés quils
sont venus à l'invitation donne même qui
n'étaient pas invités sont venus avec
l'article de journal
donc c'est vraiment qu'il ya une
problématique on est tout à fait dans le
coeur de l'action de la collectivité et
on espère que la collectif y ait été et
nous allons en tant que collectivité
faire tout pour que d'autres journées
départementales ou ou dans les
microrégions se déroule ainsi face à la
vague digital une partie de la
population réunionnaise rencontrent au
quotidien des difficultés d'ordre
financier ou de mes connaissances de
l'outil web
l'association la fusée est intervenu
afin de lutter contre cette fracture
numérique les mettre en place une
stratégie d'inclusion numériques locales
il faut savoir que 61% des seniors à
l'heure actuelle ne connaissent pas
complètement le web les outils web c'est
à dire ne serait-ce qu utiliser une
souris
ils ne savent pas faire ou d'ailleurs
faire la touche majuscule aussi ça leur
pose de réels problèmes
l'objectif aujourd'hui afin de les
rendre autonomes cd accompagné de les
aider sur les outils web donc à utiliser
la souris âme leur montrer aussi les
touches du clavier parce que pour nous
ça paraît banal mais pour eux c'est très
compliqué aussi
et de les accompagner aussi à créer une
adresse mail parce qu'aujourd'hui
sachant que tout se dématérialise il
faut à tout prix avoir une adresse mail
pour pouvoir ouvrir des comptes aussi
bien la kafka se retraite donc
l'objectif aujourd'hui c'est d'être ici
et de les accompagner afin qu'ils le bas
qui soit autonome le plus le plus
possible seniors où en êtes-vous une
première édition qui a remporté un franc
succès l'opération devrait être réitérée
prochainement